les tractations diplomatiques se
poursuivent pour tenter de sortir de la
crise il craignait hier soir joe biden
s'est entretenu au téléphone avec le
chancelier allemand olaf scholz les deux
dirigeants ont salué la volonté du chef
du kremlin de vouloir continuer sur la
voie diplomatique mais dans le même
temps les américains doutent de sa
parole il réclame des preuves du début
du retrait des militaires russes à la
frontière ukrainienne voyez là est la
correspondance à washington de notre
journaliste thomas bonnin
côté américain c'est toujours le
scepticisme qui est de mise après les
affirmations russe selon lesquelles les
troupes amassés le long de la frontière
ukrainienne sont en train de quitter la
région cela s'est confirmé lors d'un
entretien entre joe biden et olaf scholz
tous deux demandent à la russie de
véritables mesures de désescalade est un
peu plus tôt dans la journée ce mercredi
c'est le porte-parole de la diplomatie
américaine qui s'est exprimée en
affirmant ne pas voir de signe de
retrait des troupes russes mais plutôt l
inverse il estime qu'il y à un faux
narratif de la part des autorités russes
pour dit il justifier une attaque il
estime que la russie est engagée dans
une propagande sur le sujet du retrait
des troupes notre inquiétude ne se
réduit pas elle augmente déclare
notamment ned price qui affirme encore
une fois qu'une attaque pourrait se
produire à tout moment alors la question
lui a été posée sur cette date du 16
février c'est une date qui vous le savez
avait été avancé dans un certain nombre
de médias aux états unis s'appuyant sur
des éléments des services de
renseignement américains pour affirmer
que la russie pourrait lancer
l'offensive ce 16 février mais force est
de constater que rien ne s'est produit
écoutez la réponse donnée de price à ce
sujet
à l'heure où on se parle poutine peut
donner l'ordre dans vers l'ukraine à
tout moment c'est le cas depuis un
certain temps précisément parce que
l'accumulation de forces russes le long
de la frontière ukrainienne en
biélorussie ainsi que certaines
manoeuvres que l'on a constaté m la
russie en position d'agir à n'importe
quel moment c'est notre analyse actuel
cela pourrait arriver demain cela
pourrait arriver la semaine prochaine
avant la fin des jeux olympiques après
les jeux olympiques
je veux être très claire nous
inquiétudes n'ont pas diminué d'un iota
à noter qu'anthony been on sera à partir
de ce jeudi en allemagne pour la
conférence de munich sur la sécurité
l'occasion pour le chef de la diplomatie
américaine de multiplier les entretiens
bilatéraux avec les alliés européens il
sera évidemment question du dossier
ukrainien